hello everyone my name is Hugh hammer
and I am supposed to remind you to
submit your questions to the Q&A box and
I'll address those questions at the end
of this presentation so the title of my
presentation is the zebrafish husbandry
education efforts by gaston State
Community College the University of
Alabama at Birmingham and a community of
scholars from the zebrafish husbandry
Association I first like to acknowledge
all my co-authors who got me into this
mess in the first place and that is dr.
Susan farmer and dr. Stephen wats the
directors of the uod zebrafish core at
the University of Alabama at Birmingham
and also dr. samuel carter and he is the
vice president of animal research
services at the University of Alabama at
Birmingham I'd also like to acknowledge
another co-author and that it's cari
Barton she's currently the president of
the zebrafish husbandry Association and
that is an organization that has been
behind this effort from the very
beginning so let's go ahead and get
started I first want to show you guys a
little bit about where we're at I'm at
gadsden state community college and this
is in Gadsden Alabama so we are about
two and a half hours northwest of
atlanta georgia we are about an hour
north of Birmingham Alabama a little
north and east and then about an hour
southwest of Chattanooga Tennessee so
this slide kind of shows you where we're
at this is the aquaculture education and
development center against in-state
Community College and this is the
program that I manage I manage this
program with a senior technician Timothy
Adams and an assistant tabitha downs but
I am the only faculty member at this
facility it is a 26-acre facility we
have 13 of freshwater ponds we do
between 12 and 15 different species at
this facility at any given
time this facility is unique and that it
is entirely dedicated to education
there's not a lot of different research
efforts that are going out here other
than just student projects so we really
have the ability to do whatever we
really want to we also have a large
indoor hatchery spaces we have wet labs
dry labs and office space here and we
have a large dedicated classroom the
students in the program are really
encouraged to get their hands wet from
the first day that they come through the
doors and we like to have our students
get experience with everything that we
work with at the facility so in that
respect it is really unique we're also a
community college program that currently
has seven bachelor's degree students and
a lot of these bachelor students come
here because of the unique program and
they're the unique ability to get
valuable practice and valuable
experience while they're here this is
our indoor hatchery space it's about
2,000 square feet and we have about you
know forty four thousand liters of
recirculating water in this hatchery
space we have nine Independent Systems
the systems are managed by the students
and you know so they're responsible for
feeding their fish and taking care of
their tanks and all that fun stuff on
there also responsible for the ponds and
the pond work that goes out here so they
really get a good chance to get a lot of
different experiences this is our
dedicated classroom space our classroom
space is used only for this program and
it really gives us the ability to do a
lot of different types of workshops for
about the last 15 years we've had a
teacher aquaculture effort and it's been
a you know a very very strong project
for this particular program we've
trained about 400 different school
teachers
over the last several years this is our
greenhouse system in our greenhouse we
have an aquaponic and hydroponic
production systems so we produce some
plant materials as well and we also have
a 17,000 gallon in the ground biofloc
system these are some of the animals
that we aquaculture here we have marine
ornamentals we do tilapia freshwater
prawns rainbow trout when it's in season
we can do hybrid striped striped bass
here we do channel catfish of course
largemouth bass and Sun fishes and also
ornamental koi so we have the ability to
do a wide variety of animals here and
then of course we do zebrafish and
that's going to be the rest of this
presentation um you know no introduction
to the program would be complete without
really addressing and talking about the
students we rely on our students very
heavily out here as I had mentioned to
you I'm the only faculty member out here
and there's are just a few staff members
so we really rely heavily on the
students to do the things that we need
to do out here and and they're really
great about helping us get all the work
done so what is zebrafish well zebrafish
is danio rerio okay it's a small
tropical fish native to Southeast Asia
it's native to the modern countries of
Malaysia Bangladesh and India it is a
very well-known tropical hobbyist fish
because it is very very tough it can
handle a wide variety of water chemistry
conditions and a wide variety of growing
conditions it's some of these same
characteristics that have made it a
popular research model according to the
zebrafish information networkers Ethan
there are about 780 laboratories
worldwide that are registered on zan the
number of different laboratories using
zebrafish as a model for research in the
u.s. very similar between 300 and 500
laps but what's kind of interesting
about all of this is that there are
really no training programs for
technicians that work with these fish
anywhere in the world and so that's what
we're trying to do here some of you may
be asking well why zebrafish well
probably the biggest reason zebrafish
are used as a research model is that
they have transparent embryos that are
fertilized externally and these embryos
during their early development show all
of the higher vertebrate characteristics
so that it makes makes them a very
useful organism to manipulate for
genetics and for mutations and all kinds
of other different developmental work
that might want to be done on the fish
are also very prolific breeders breeding
pairs can be bred out more than once a
week and they can lay large numbers of
eggs you know and that reproduction can
be very tightly controlled so that you
know the exact age of the embryos
zebrafish also go to reproductive age
pretty quickly most laboratories can get
them to a reproductive age in less than
60 days as I'd already previously
mentioned zebrafish are pretty Hardy
aquatic species they can handle a wide
variety of different growing
environments and a wide variety of
different you know physical
manipulations and water chemistry
parameters so they're very good model to
work with in that respect they're also
economically competitive with mice
zebrafish require less infrastructure
you can hold large numbers of animals
and very very confined spaces and you
know that makes them more economically
competitive with mice the genome for
zebra fish has been sequenced and there
are already a number a large number of
different genetic lines and different
mutations that are available to the
research community so all of these
things are
very good reasons why zebrafish has
become an increasingly popular research
model on the lower right-hand part of
this slide you can see that out of the
percy animal procedures performed in
2011 that fifteen percent of those
procedures were done on fish and this
came from the BBC guide to animal ethics
this is a slide sequence that shows the
early development of zebrafish as it
would be observed under a light
microscope zebrafish developed very
quickly by about two and a half days
post fertilization or DPF zebrafish will
typically hatch if they're raised under
standard conditions and they'll actually
begin feeding by day five so this slide
shows you the growth of zebrafish
research so this is this shows the
number of annual publications that have
used zebrafish as a keyword you know
from the different journals and you can
see that you know in 2012 there were
over 1,800 publications that use the BIR
fish as a keyword showing its tremendous
growth in popularity zebrafish made the
cover of science magazine in 2005 again
this shows you know they're increasing
popularity with all of this growth and
all of this use of zebrafish for
biomedical research there's also been
problems as the infrastructure the
knowledge of the organism the culture
techniques the nutrition and the
laboratory practices struggle to keep
pace with just the use of the animal for
other forms of research many medical
researchers and veterinarians that have
worked their entire careers with rodent
models are really unfamiliar with fish
and fish culture and its limitations and
its advantages and so that has created
some problems also
since the model has grown so rapidly
there are a lot of discrepancies between
the different laboratories in how they
treat their fish how the fish are
cultured and the different techniques
that have that go into the research for
example there are big differences among
laboratories in what the animals are fed
how often they're fed and how the you
know growing environments are managed
this has the of the problem of creating
discrepancies between different research
laboratories and also it has the
potential to create problems with the
validity of research you know because
any one of these factors can have
tremendous impacts on research results
and so one of the needs for this
community is to better standardized
research methods for zebrafish husbandry
care and culture and also to better
train individuals within the industry to
use this fish as a model in 2010 at a
u.s. aquaculture meeting in San Diego
California we got a phone call the
zebrafish husbandry association was
having their annual workshop and they
had identified you know some of these
needs for better trained labor for more
standardized methods and we got a phone
call you know I was actually reading to
my young boy and got a phone call late
that night and they asked us you know
would you be interested in working with
a group to develop a curriculum for
zebrafish husbandry education is
absolutely and that resulted in a
conference call and with these folks
here dr. watts dr. Trevorrow Chris
Lawrence from Boston Children's George
Sanders from University of Washington
school of medicine dan castronovo from
the NIH and myself and it was the result
of this conference call that got
everything moving in this direction and
this really became our core group of you
know supporters to get this effort
underway after this conference call on
the University of Alabama at Birmingham
zebrafish core became a full partner the
University of Alabama at Birmingham is a
world-class research campus that has a
very large well-funded animal research
program or a RP they are very familiar
with all the animal models and with
biomedical research on there in very
close proximity to Gadsden State
Community College only about an hour
away and so that makes them a perfect
partner Gaston state you know we
specialize in aquaculture technical
training and education UAB specializing
in world-class biomedical research
animal models and you know research for
laboratory animal care the recently
opened up their zebrafish core that was
in 2011 it's about 6,000 square feet it
has all of the you know latest equipment
for husbandry filtration and food prep
embryo injection quarantine and they
have great pathology facilities and that
zebrafish core is managed by partners in
this effort dr. Susan farmer and dr.
Stephen watts and that whole project is
overseen by dr. samuel carter is the
associate vice president of animal
research at UAB the
step was to see if we could get funding
to get this effort off the ground and so
we sent proposals and you know went to
several different agencies to ask them
if we could get support for this effort
you know a group that I'm very familiar
with the USDA they declined and said
well this wasn't really their area of
expertise even though it was an
aquaculture related area and then we
went to a km g laz and a lass
foundations or groups and these are
foundations and groups that have their
mission statement to support laboratory
animal care and research and ironically
none of them would really accept the
proposal from us because they said it
had to be original research and we were
doing an educational program so at that
point you know with everybody kind of
saying no we decided well heck we're
just going to do it ourselves and so
this was a meeting that happened in
February of 2012 it was a meeting
between the faculty are the upper
administration at gadsden state
community college and some of the upper
administration at the University of
Alabama at Birmingham including the vice
president of research dr. richard maher
case and at this meeting dr. mark case
brought a check for ten thousand dollars
to get the effort started and it was
also during this meeting that both
Gadsden State and the University of
Alabama at Birmingham pledged personnel
time and pledged facilities and
resources to get this effort going and
so this was the beginning
with this effort we had a really unique
challenge we needed to design an
entirely new curriculum based on the
needs for the animal care staff and
based on the needs of the zebrafish you
know researchers the different
researchers that would be using this
model and so we had a lot of unique
needs that we needed to address I mean
first we had to find out what those
needs were we also needed to make this
content available to a very large and
very diverse audience at both the
national and potentially an
international level we also knew that if
we were going to be truly effective we
had to be able to combine just the
theory and the content with actual
hands-on experiences excuse me and last
but not least you know this kind of
aquaculture is not something that we're
really familiar with as an aquaculture
group because it's really done a very
kind of unique systems that you know
that are provided by several different
vendors and you know have some you know
kind of unique qualities to them so the
movie we would need a lot of help with
this effort so the next step was really
reconnaissance we had to find out what
these people needed and so we started
with a preliminary survey that went out
to the zebrafish listserv and this kind
of gave us an idea about of what we were
going to be up against and then in 2011
I was invited to the zebrafish husbandry
Association's annual excuse me annual
workshop that was in New Orleans
Louisiana and at this workshop we
redistributed a pretty pretty good
survey a pretty detailed survey of what
the workforce needed and wanted the
results of that survey when they came
back and we kind of guard over
everything we found that really that
there was a huge need for qualified
technicians not only all over the
country but actually all over the world
and that there were very specific
knowledge and skills that they needed
that
they wanted from their technicians we
found out that a lot of these jobs paid
very well and almost all of them had
very generous benefits packages and we
also found out from the group that they
wanted a combination of online training
and hands-on workshops and so this
really gave us a good outline for what
we needed to do the next step was to
recruit our team and so the next year at
the zebrafish husbandry association's
annual workshop in Las Vegas Nevada I
was set with the task of putting a team
together to lead this effort I basically
chased down and pestered the heck out of
every expert I could find it got so bad
that people would see me coming down the
hall and they would turn the other way
and but at the end of the day I was able
to recruit 18 world experts in zebrafish
husbandry and that would complement our
group from gaston state and our group
from UAB it was also very important that
some of these members be from the vendor
reps that sell the different growing
apparatus or the rack systems that we
were going to need for this effort and
we were able to secure one member from
each of the major vendors to work with
us on this so that was incredibly
important as well so the plan we wanted
to construct a very detailed online
course through Gadsden State Community
College the online course was going to
have four parts that we called modules
and each module would contain six to ten
presentations of different topics on all
of these presentations would be scripted
and voiced over using studio software
and they would all contain online
quizzes that we would be able to use to
test student knowledge so that was the
online course the second part of the
effort was going to be the actual
hands-on workshops
and so we are going to start doing
four-day three-night hands-on workshops
at gadsden state community college each
year and during these workshops will be
emphasizing not the content so much that
was given in the online portion of the
course but we will be emphasizing the
hands-on skills basic culture skills
spawning and larval culture water
chemistry analysis and interpretation
systems maintenance and health
management so you know this was the plan
so how are we going to get this thing
started you know and so we needed some
quality time with our team of experts
and we decided that we were going to
hold a project development workshop at
gadsden state and bring our team out to
Gadsden Alabama so how in the heck do
you get these eighteen incredibly busy
world experts to travel hundreds of
miles at their own expense and work
their tails off in no way Alabama for
three days well it's simple worldwide we
told them that they had won an
extravagant five-day four-night vacation
package to a five-star resort and spa
and then when they arrived we lock them
into a room and we didn't let them out
until we got what we want well just kind
of kidding but we picked them up at
birmingham airport and we transported
them to a hotel in the Gadsden area the
next morning we got them all up and we
got them all to the facility and we
started dividing them up into teams
working teams and so we put them in
pairs and sometimes trios and they were
all assigned a topic to work on that was
based on their expertise and we had
several working sessions over the
workshop over the several the three days
of the workshop and we had all of our
meals catered into the classroom to keep
everybody on task and then during the
evenings we took the group out to
different restaurants and just you know
had some time to wind down in the
evenings
everybody in the group reported that
this was one of the best you know
workshops or whatever that they had ever
attended and that they had a great time
while working their tails off it was
really exciting so these were our
workshop participants and as you can see
it's really we're developing kind of a
who's who list for you know zebrafish
experts here so really good stuff and
this is a picture of everybody at Gaston
state also the president of gadsden
state and the Dean of instruction the
workshop was here during June so you
know really warm weather but in June
down here we're already in the 90s all
the time so so this is the online course
the first module is water chemistry it
contains seven presentations the second
module is systems infiltration and it
contains six presentations on systems
and filtration module 3 is colony
management and nutrition and it has
seven presentations and module for
health management facilities and
compliance and it currently has seven
presentations it is our intent that once
this is completed we will be updating
all of these presentations as they need
to be to keep the information as current
as possible and that's one of the
reasons why you know we wanted to kind
of manage this whole project ourselves
during the workshop we also took some
time out to have a little bit of fun
this workshop was going on in the heart
of our channel catfish season here in
Alabama and so I got all these lab rats
out and got him wet and dirty we send up
a bunch of adult channel catfish I'm in
upon those fish would later be consumed
at the end of the workshop banquet and
they also got the chance to harvest
channel catfish eggs and take those into
the hatchery and hatch amount so we put
some time to have some fun as well
this is our group's commitment to the
well-being of fish if you know some of
these people Chris Lawrence christine
lee ji George Sanders Eric Sanders it
was just on just before me some more
pictures from the from the workshop so
where are we with this effort now we
have 27 drafts of presentations that
have already you know got the content
outlined and been reviewed by the group
gadsden state folks myself and dr. Susan
farmer from UAB are working on these
every week we're also you know have
various team members that are working on
them each week the University of Alabama
at Birmingham is hosting webinars every
two weeks with our team to go over
different presentations and to clean
those up we have about half of those
presentations scripted and we're voicing
them over now we've got the art
department at gadsden state that's
helping us to clean up the graphics of
the presentations we hope to offer the
first online course by the summer of
2014 so by this summer and we will be
having our first hands-on workshop here
hopefully in August of 2014 so you can
stay tuned to our website to keep track
of where we're at with the effort and
eventually to actually sign up to take
the course while building the course we
also had to bet it build some dedicated
spaces for zebrafish education and so we
had to completely renovate this wet lab
space we took it all the way down to the
studs and we had to put in new floors
and you know change the walls we changed
everything in this room and as you can
see we've got wax from all the different
major vendors all in one place so that's
going to be great and right now we're
actually growing fish in this room every
day and we're spawning fish every week
and we also have live feed cultures
going on so the students that are
currently in my program are getting
lots and lots of experience when it's
not in use for the workshops these are
other spaces that we renovated just for
you know the zebrafish work and finally
the students you know we've been
generating null train students from the
very beginning of this effort you know
Kim tice dinner internship at boston
children's hospital with Chris Lawrence
she's now employed at the nih kayla
smith is employed at the University of
Arkansas at Pine Bluff as a technician
and she's getting to work some with
trace Peterson who came out of Michael
Kent slab in Oregon Allison's ainley and
Rebecca Graham are on full scholarships
at the university of arkansas pine bluff
in the fisheries aquaculture program but
they all did zebrafish work here Claire
Johnston gossiped is looking to probably
go into vet school as an aquatic vet you
know because of her interest in this
Cassie Craddock did her internship at
Tulane University School of Medicine
with zebra fish and Brandi Klein Heiser
she was our first student here at Gaston
state that did zebrafish stuff and she's
now a full-time employee at the UAB
zebrafish core and actually is a protect
to one of the professors that works in
the Corps there and then now we have
currently 35 students at Gaston State
six of those have bachelor's degrees and
nine of the students are here really
almost to do zebrafish work exclusively
and we have a we actually have another
student who's an intern from a nearby
university and she's here just to do
zebrafish as well
this is a rack card that we generated
for the effort and you can pick one of
these up it then local and national
meetings any time any of our vendors are
there they should have these rack cards
available to hand out to you it kind of
gives you some information and
background on what I've just talked
about tell you a little bit about the
members of the team and the different
folks that are involved and where to
keep up with the progress on this effort
I can't thank the members of my
education team enough and that
membership has actually grown now so we
keep adding people as we need to and as
more people become is interested in
being involved in the exciting stuff
that we're doing here so you know but
this team I mean came here and they
worked their tails off and and really
they continue to work really hard at
this effort you know each and every week
modifying presentations and really
working with us so it's good stuff this
work could not have been done without
the support of all of our vendors with
the support that initial support from
the University of Alabama at Birmingham
and the continuing support of the
zebrafish husbandry Association so huge
thank you to those folks and at this
time I'm done so if you have questions
please go ahead and submit those on the
q and a bar and i'll take care of that
and you know just you can keep up with
us on our website this is our website
here so hopefully that'll stay on the
screen for a few minutes and you can
write that down if you need to and kind
of keep up with our progress on the
website and i'll turn it over to you
guys for questions at this point so
thanks very much for your attention and
time
the first question I have is what is the
estimated cost for the training that
will begin this summer and that hasn't
been completely decided yet but one of
the things that we're looking at is that
it will probably be a for credit course
in which case it's we're going to have
to charge the credit hour rate for
Gadsden State which means for
out-of-state tuition it would cost about
$300 300 to 350 dollars to take the
course for the actual hands-on workshop
you know we're looking at numbers you
know we've run some numbers and we have
kind of an idea what it's going to cost
and that sort of thing it will be an
all-inclusive type of effort where all
you have to do is get to Birmingham
International Airport we'll pick you up
there will they need a Gadsden and will
have your hotel rooms and all of your
meals taken care of already and I think
for that three-day four-night workshop
it's probably going to cost you know
around eighteen hundred dollars it's
kind of the number that we're looking at
right now but that has not been
finalized yet and you know we're still
working through that with you know the
team and with you know our upper
administration as well at both you ABM
Gaston state so hopefully that answers
the question any other questions
excuse me so rosalina i don't know that
i have any other questions at this point
in time so do i just stay on here are
the other questions coming in